O ne o
[Müzik]
abone ol
bu Hoş geldiniz Herkes bana atabilir mi
evet Hadi bana bakıyorum Evet şimdi
o lütfen Gözleriniz aşkım
ama yarın da kipa'dan gözlerini
söyleyebilirsiniz
ne oldu
abone ol
ve
belki de hayatınızı değiştirecek olan şu
yanınızda oturuyor ama siz ona bakma
mısınız
Evet şimdi herkes yanındaki gözlerine
bakabilirim
mi
Evet vakit
Ben hayatımı değiştirmeye başladı bile
o
Kimin ne zaman ayağınızı
değiştireceğinizi geçimin ne zaman
hayatınız kesip Onunla beraber
hayatınızı bambaşka bir boyuta düşündük
geçeceğini bilemezsiniz O yüzden açmıyor
gözlerinizi Hoş geldiniz
Evet
o zaman başlıyor
Allah herkesin hayatta
bir şekilde yolu kesişir kestikten
sonrada bir çok değişik yaşadığını
biliyoruz dünyada Bununla ilgili çok
fazla örnek var var mesela aşkla
meslekte bu kestikten sonra Aslında
bilimle ilgili birçok ufkunda açılıyor
kapılarının açılıyor olduğunu görüyor Ve
Mesleğimi olmasaydı belki Einstein bugün
bu kadar popüler ya da bu kadar büyük
işler yapamayacaktır
o zaman mantık Zorlu okul koçuyla yolun
kesi olması ona senin basketbola
yeteneğin yok dipolo takımdan çıkarıyor
olmasıyla hızlanması ve bulursan dolayı
da bugün hala diğer basketbolcuların
onun rekorları kırıyor olmak için
çalışıyor olmasına sebep olması ya da
birçok kendi alışı Symbol fiyatları
Yolları kestikten sonra
bu evlerde bireysel bilgisayarını
ihtiyaç var
Ben bilmem ve bunu hiç bir kere iyi
olmadığını düşünen bir dönemde bugün
hepimizin hayatında bilgisayar olması
her evde bilgisayar olmasını sağlayan
bir dönüşmeleri değişime yol açtı
olmasıdır biliyorsun
da
dinledikten sonra
onun gibi olmak için çalışıyor olmaları
birlikte bir grup kurma isteklerinin
oluşması ve sonrasında çok daha
fazlasını yaptılar bizi denizin bir
kilometre taşı olarak Bugün dünyanın
kılmayan raporlarıyla Hatta büyük
çoğunluğu zaman hayatta değil ölülerini
bile her yıl milyonlarca sterlin kazandı
büyük bir şöhrete sahiptir
işte bizdeki olduğunu biliyor muydunuz
renkleri çok büyük sorunlarla
problemlerle ilgili mücadele ediyor ve
sonrasında asla kendini değiştiriyor çok
zor bir hayatı var fakirlikle
zorluklarla uğraşıyor ve bir komedyen
izliyor bir komedyenle yolu kesişiyor ve
dünyanın en önemli problemlerinden
birisi oluyor ve her zaman bunu bu
gururla söylüyor bir komedyen izledim
hayatım değişti ve seni de benzer bir
hikayesi var boyu uzamıyor futbol
yeteneği var ama tedavisi çok masrafı
ilk futbol takımı transfer etmek
istemiyor ve hatta biri olan ki yok yani
cansız
Barcelona
Tedavi masraflarını karşılıyor ve
bugün olması sağladıkları için hiçbir
zaman ödeyebileceği gibi zamanda
ayrılıyor ki bu böyleydi
Evet Ee elinden tutmuş salardı altı
futbol topu karşılığında transfer
etmeseler de belki de dünyanın en önemli
futbolcularından birisi olmayacaktı
İyiki Barcelona ile yolu kesişmiş Ben de
bunu küçük örneklerinden birisini
aslında
o
kelimeyi bir araya getiremiyorum
zaten olmamış mı
Evet şimdi öyle değil mi
O
nasıl oldu böyle bunun için her zaman
şunu söyleyelim doğru zamanda doğru
yerde doğru getiriyoruz geçtiğinde
Aslında hayatınızla ilgili yollarımız ve
yapacaklarımızı sınırı Gerçekten
inanılmaz boyutlara ulaşıyor
1995 yılında TRT 1 Diriliş TV televizyon
karatosun bir sınavına katıldı
sonrasında Aslında bu kadar
konuşma ile ilgili olan problemi çözmek
için Çivi çiviyi söker arkadaş diyerek
Beni bununla ilgili en yapacağım şey
rahat olur Radyo gidersen ben bu işlemi
bütün problemlerini çözelim düşüncesiyle
girdim ve o günden sonra hayatım gelişti
bugün TRT de çok uzun yıllardır çok
farklı konumlarda yerlerde programlar
yapıyorum Evet seslendirme sanatçısı
olarak da çalışıyormuş o kendi
dinlersiniz tanımazsınız Annem de
tanımıyorum seslendirdiği başka bir iş
sadece o karakteri ürün tüm de beni
tanıyor biliyorsunuz ve benim için
gerçekten çok büyük bir yeri vardır
ablamın bu burada 25 yılın sayısız
bilmediğim kadar başarılı ve hikaye
Bitirdim Bu benim için çok büyük bir
gurur ve radyonun en büyük İşte
savaşçılarından birisi değildir Çünkü
hak ettiği yere gelmesi zaman
düşünüyorum Bu ülkede ne kadar yerinden
gelen çorba varsa göstereceğim radyoda
bu başarıyı sürdürmek için 25 günü
geride bıraktım ve hatta Oscar verdiler
bana inşallah gerçek Oscar aldığım
günlerini gördüm Tokat aslında hiç
problem değil Yeter ki Oscar'ı
alabilirim ve bir kitap okudum Sevgili
Kitabı O kitapta benim hayatımı
değiştirdi O yüzden okumaktan hiçbir
zaman vazgeçmeyin
Evet Ee belki hepinizin ağzına zamanda
böyle
Köşebaşı kitapları başucu kitapları ama
insan mühendisliği mutlaka okunması
gereken kitaplardan ve boş
kitaplarımızda birisi olması gerekiyor
ve benim hayatımda çok büyük bir yeri
var evindeki sizde okudukça hayatınızda
çok fazla değil değiştireceksiniz
sonrasında benim koşup hayatımın ya da
İnsanların hayatına Dokunma yolculuğun
başlangıcında vesile olduğu gibi
akademiye sahip şu an ve çok güzel
başarı hikayeleri yazıyoruz da benim
için çok büyük bir gurur uzun yıllardır
İnsanların hayatına dokunuyor olmak için
gerçekten çok kıymetli bugün Türkiye'nin
dört bir köşesinde eğitimler Seminerler
veriyorum Ve tabiki phileas sahnesinde
bulunuyor olmak bir bütün bambaşka ondan
da bahsediyor olacağım Hatta korku
Federasyonu Bununla ilgili önemli iki
buçuk unvanını verdi bu da benim için
çok büyük bir onurdur Bu da elinden gel
da ilave ediyorum ve
kitabını okuduktan sonra başka bir hayal
dünyasına götüren ilk kişi olan iller
uzaylı bugün Türkiye'nin dört bir
köşesinde sevilenler veriyoruz bir kitap
okursunuz hayalini kurduğunuz şey gerçek
olur Hayal edersiniz o hayali
gerçekleştirir daha fazlasını Yaparsınız
bir kitapla Yolumuz kesişir dünyanın
Selam bugün ilk üniversite öğrencisi
yanıma gelip Ben okulda dokunmak
istiyorum ve bununla ilgili olarak
sizden yardım istiyorum dediğinde ben ne
yapabilirim ki diye düşünürken dedim
elimden geleni yaparım ve yaptık Fatih
Üniversitesi'nin radyosunu kurduk bugün
aktif olarak çalışıyor ve bizim bir
bebeğimiz çok da keyifle çok daha güzel
bir şekilde yayınlana devam ediyor
sonrasında Atılım Üniversitesi radyosu
kurduk bir üniversite öğrencisi yok
geçişte bugün üniversitelerin radyoları
o kullandıklarını kuruyoruz onların
yayıncıların yetiştiriyoruz geleceği
radyocuların yetiştiriyoruz bakıp hepsi
bugün Radyo programcısı olan Belki de
mesleklerin yanında bu iş yapmaya devam
edecek olan insanlar oluyor Ve bu da
benim için çok ama çok birlikte
her güne
bir hocamız var iyisi olacağız oluyorum
ve sonrasında Tiyatro ve tiyatro
birlikte hayatında çok şeyler değişti
Herkes için her kırılma başka bir kapıyı
beraberinde sürüyor açıyor tek gitti tek
gittiğimiz ve sorun nereye gittiğini
bilmediğini videoda birden fazla şerit
ve birden fazla vitesinin olduğun hayata
dönüyoruz herkes ismiyle pek şerefli bir
köy yolu bir anda 10 seri bir hoca bir
Otobana dönüşebiliyor O yüzden
hayatınızda ne kadar çok kişiyle
hayatınız gidiyorsa o size o kadar
Aslında çok daha geniş Platformu Lara ve
noktalara taşır hale geliyor sonrasında
shefa gelir olup ya işte belki
görmüşsünüzdür Fox ürettiği Şafak
edebilir
aileden gelen bir hastalık serverimiz
var merakımdan özel zevkinden ve bu çok
sevdiğimden yollarımız kesişti bu
Türkiye'de ilk ve tek olan eğlenceli
yemek atölyesi Türk'ten falan isimli bir
yanar atölyesi düzenliyor 10 yıldır
devam ediyor bu kapalıydı insanlar Çok
Ama Çok meraklılar dışı buna gibi bir
açık vardı kapattığımız düşünüyoruz ve
bence çok büyük keyif alıyorum mutfakta
olmakta bu kadar soğuk yapıyorum
ama
ben seviyorum kendim sonrasında birçok
yemek yarışmasında etkilemek markasında
hafta gıda firmasında farklı şekillerde
farklı çalışmalar yaptık reklam üzere
olduğunuz gibi yarışmaları sunduğu jüri
üyeliği yaptığı bir sürü farklı şeyler
de bulundum Yani bir kişiyle yolumuzu
kesişmesi sizi o platformda Başka
yerleri çok hızlı bir şekilde götürüyor
sonrasında okuduğum kitaplardan kendimi
ifade Edebilir hale gelmek için ben de
bir kitap yazan hale geldim eski bir
kitap Aslında yeni kitabın Çok yakında
çıkacak piyasaya ya onda da yeter ki
iste ineceğiz birşeyleri gerçekleştirmek
istediğinizde bir şey de çok da fazla
seksi olmamız alakalı hikaye anlatıyor
olacağız ve bugün hayalini kurduğum
benim için önemli olan bir akademiny
sahibiyim kendini geliştirmek isteyenler
de bir yolculukla çıkıyoruz çok güzel
işler başlıyoruz Türkiye'de TED
konuşması estetiği eğitimleri veriyor ve
sonrasında gelip bana şey diyorlar Nasıl
bu kadar böyle iki tane tane hiç
durmadan nasıl yapıyorsunuz vardır
çalışmak Yani biz yapabiliriz Bunu
sadece yapmak isteyip fazla geliştirmek
isteyin değiştirirsiniz Peki ne zaman
yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam
bir YouTube etkinliği gençlerin
hayatında onlara yol göstermek için
böyle olmamız bunun içinde sizin
hikayenizi anlatmak istiyoruz dediler
dedesi Yolumuz geçmiş şu an Türkiye'nin
dört bir köşesinde kendi hayat hikayemi
ve bugün ilham veren konuşmalar yapmak
için elinden geleni yapıyorum bu Burada
olduğumuz için de Sizin de yolunuz
kesiştiği içinde çok ama çok mutluyum
İyi ki geldiniz İyiki Yolumuz kes işte o
[Alkış]
bu
aa yanlış
ben genelde böyle Aslında Aferin
kelimesi İngilizce poster kimyon
öğrenmenin İlkadım'da cümlesinin başı
ama biz bugün
hayatınıza öyle bir gerek
yerleştiriyoruz yanlış başarısızlık hata
Tam öyle bastırıyoruz ki bunu kabul
ediyoruz ama dünkü Aslında öğreniyoruz
yaptığınız hatalar belki yanlış yerde
yanlış noktada bulunmaktan yanlış şeyler
de bulduğumuzu kesilmesinden dolayı
yaşadıklarımız da bizi büyütüyor hatalar
diye gördüklerimiz aslında bizi olduğunu
araştırıyor Mevlana ediyor her
yaşadığımız yok kabuğumu kalınır Aslında
olduğunda söylediğiniz şey kalmamış
kalınlaşıyor olabilir ama bizi çok daha
iyi yerlere bu tarz sürekli taşıyacaktır
iki şehri görüşüyoruz yeterince
öğreniyoruz değişmek istiyoruz ya da
yeter ki yaralanıyoruz değişmek zorunda
kalıyoruz
her ikisinde de mutlaka a
Bu bir değişim var ve ikisini mutlaka
hayatımızda yeri var tek taraflı olmuyor
İkisi de mutlaka hayatımızda var ve
olmaya da devam edecek yani ilişkiyi
sürdüreceğiz Ancak bu noktada şüphe
ettiğiniz hepsi var
ya boş ver Siz olmayacağız Çünkü
gücünüzden küfür ederseniz şüphelerimiz
3 veririz bizim şüphelere git vermek
gibi isteriz yok tam tersi kendinize
güvenmeye inanmaya ve bunun için çok
çalışmaya ihtiyacım var Eğer çok
çalışıyorsanız kendinize güveniyorsanız
gücünüze inanıyorsanız o gün sizi
İstediğiniz yere mutfak sürede
götürecektir yapacağınız tek şey
yüzünüzden şüphe etmek pek düştüklerini
sallıyorsunuz ya
bu altyazı sallıyorsunuz Eğer
görüştüklerini sarmaya devam ederseniz
kattıklarını hiçbir anlamı olmayacak
bugün hayattaysa
düştükten sonra kalkmışım demektir
aferin yok düştüm ben hep düşünüyorum
Yine Düştün Yine Düştüm Bak yine düştüm
düşeceğim ama hiç kalktım yok O nedenle
Öncelikle düştüklerini değil
taptıklarınızı sayıyor olmayıp yanımız
var
o zaman içerisinde problemler
yaşayabilirsiniz ara beni
iyi görünüyor mobil
bu birazcık diyeceğim de sen Tepesi
var ama biz pes etme konusunda bir anda
vazgeçip her şeyi yapıp yapmama
konusunda
inanılmaz mı böyle bir başka istemiyoruz
bizim istediğimiz ara vermek dinlenme
kaldığımız yerden devam et Eğer
kaldığımız yerden devam ederseniz
düştükten sonra da kalkıyor mu
bilirsiniz zaten istediklerinizi çok
hızlı bir şekilde
ele geçireceksiniz dedik ya bir yolumuz
gelişmiş diye bazıları vardır ki hepimiz
için ilk yolumuzu kesiştiği diye
düşündüğünüz ve hepimizin hayatını
değiştirdiğini düşündüğünüz bu sabah
Kemal adı ilk yolu kesişmiş ilk bugün
Buralara Kadar geldiğimizi sağlamış İyi
ki var
[Alkış]
sizin gençliğimiz
var yani geçtiğimizde hiçbir şey hiçbir
şey için çalışır etme hazinenin
kıymetini bilin geçtiğinizde kıymetini
bildiğimiz asla bir hazine o hazineyle
kadar iyi kullandınız ne kadar iyi
temsil ettiğimiz göreceksiniz O hazineli
kıymetli bildiğiniz de o sizi çok daha
güzel çok daha iyi yerlere götürecek
abone ol
bir insan
bu Pizza
daha fazla sorunlar yaşıyoruz
Evet Tamam olur
ne zorluklar
ne zorluklar başarısızlıklar
yaşadığımızı kaybederiz Burası uğraşırız
ama olmaz
Bu bir yolu kesişir
hayatımız değişir
Ama bir gün yerde gerçekten ışığımızı
bulmanızı sağlayacak bir yol uzun
geçmesi dileğiyle
O çok teşekkür ederim
sağ ol